what's that so that's paul's last words
is you just go to church you know find
an estuary or at least some club like a
knitting club or something like you know
be connected with people build your
family ships with people that's right
learn to learn to build relationships
with people because again my sense is
with a lot of younger people like you're
right when we were growing up
you were just with people there wasn't
any of these screens to be
with people through or to have this
deceptive form of community and those
are skills
you need to learn to develop and it's a
lot better than having a six-pack or
being your ideal weight or getting some
great degree or some you know some uber
great job the the the skill of
interpersonal relationship is the most
one of the most important skills you can
develop in your lifetime and
there's no other way to do it but by
doing it with people in real life
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so how do we it so let's just say hi to
everybody because we don't know it's
like we don't know how to introduce it
conversation with you paul and jonathan
yeah we we
the
thunder bay conference is coming up
where john vervicky jonathan and i are
going to be meeting with another
professor from
um from thunder bay that's coming up in
september i've got this trip that i
leave next uh less than a week from now
for europe
trying to sort of gather and strengthen
the estuary groups and i'll be talking
to a bunch of people and so i asked john
and jonathan to meet john is traveling
today so he couldn't meet and
what well why don't we why don't we talk
about
well why don't we talk about the status
of the conversation i put out a video uh
last week when i got back i had some
personal vacation time that i was taking
and then i listened the the video
dropped of your conversation with john
and david fuller which i thought was a
terrific video and i also thought that
your conversation with jordan and john
to me that
that conversation felt like
okay we're sort of getting things back
on track in some ways almost all the way
from 2018 you me and john have sort of
kept um pecking away at this jordan's
kind of been on the outside i thought
your conversation with jordan right when
he got back was outstanding
but how i mean where do you see
we were talking about consciousness
that's what the conference in thunder
bay is going to be about
we're talking about attention i thought
jordan's conversation with ian mcgill
chris was very interesting i haven't
watched yours with him yet um
so
where do you see
well let's talk about the conversation
then let's talk about the embodiment so
where do you see the state of the
conversation right now
well the first thing to say too is
that the conversation that jordan just
put up with john viveki and the
conversation that happened with david
fuller those two parts those were filmed
like two days like on this oh like one
day after the other and so there's like
a there's a through line in terms of the
conversations there's a
you know there's there's a not a mood
but there's there's a lot of things
boiling that we ended up covering you
know both in the conversation with
jordan then also in our conversation
together because we record actually
recorded this conversation with jordan
first and then the other the next the
conversation that came out uh earlier we
recorded after so some of it was
actually going back over some of the
things we talked about with jordan um
and so i think that i think that
things are moving
at least to me things are moving in the
right direction and you know i also did
some discussions with some more
cognitive scientists ian
and renato uh castrop and also don
hoffman
to to kind of
see if the ideas that we're playing with
in terms of
in terms of first of all the the primacy
of attention
also in terms of what you could call the
levels right i think that's how you talk
about it the idea of a fractal
relationship between these different
levels so kind of self-same structures
that embody themselves uh embed
themselves into each other um
if those
make sense to them like if they make
sense to these other cognitive
scientists and the answer is yes like it
really there seems to be although you
know
in both of my discussion with with don
and with bernardo for example there were
some things that that kind of scraped a
little bit you know the don hoffman's
idea of like the vr glasses like he
doesn't see he doesn't have this sense
that john verbaki for example talked
about beauty as revealing he also he
sees it completely as a
as a almost like a lie like as if our
experience of the world is this lie and
i was trying to push him to say like
okay well then what like you know
so so i think that i think that
everything is kind of moving along and
what i'm noticing is that more and more
people are understanding
what the subject is they're
understanding what it is that we're
talking about they're also understanding
this question of level i think most
people understand that now and how
attention
let's say something like the highest
form of attention is something like
worship
that
one a part of the highest form of
attention is something like sacrifice
that sacrifice and worship are related
um
and that
that is what creates
bodies and that it's not just about
something that happens mentally is that
the sacrifice of attention the sacrifice
of worship creates the body
in which we then
move you know uh and so so i think that
that's i think that that's where we are
that most people would kind of
understand that and understand that it
it happens individually in you right it
happens at it at in terms of families in
terms of teams in terms of the church
and also happens in parasitic ways
sometimes when we talk about
when we talk about demons or parasitic
processes that are both individual and
social or at larger scales that we can
see this
these we can most people now i think not
most people may i don't know most people
at least a good group of people
understand what this is about and it can
now make sense of something like angels
and demons and a lot of the language
that is in scripture in a way that
doesn't seem arbitrary to them that
seems now like okay this is actually
this is not just like a declaration of
someone who says he saw god and god told
him to say something and now he says it
now this is saint paul is describing
reality in ways that are extremely
powerful and that if we can just
have the key to what he's saying that it
it's it's as relevant as anything these
cognitive scientists are saying
so i think that i hope that's where we
are maybe it's more of a hope that i'm
expressing
well i i think i think at least those
who are following these conversations
um i think people are
getting
you know even even the way in which we
grasp or appropriate this knowledge
is
is not
um the way in which we
in a modernist frame imagine
what knowledge is and how we appropriate
it
i don't know if that makes any sense
because i think
you know when i look at what's not just
information it's not just you can't just
get it from accumulating information
there's a
there's a change that happens it has to
happen like a like a you know a
conversion we could say you know in a
small c conversion that needs to happen
or else people will think and you've
seen it like people are some people are
saying oh there it's all gibberish what
they're saying is just a bunch of
gibberish
because they listen they hear but they
don't because they can't see the
how what it is what it is that
you have to change your world view but
basically to really understand it and
that's not a mental process it's
something which is actually precedes
mental processes it's like a insight an
intuition it's a i don't know
it's it's a vision yeah
and i think
so you know i when i listen to these
conversations i always try to
see if i can translate it into terms
that people who maybe didn't go to
college
or i mean the kind of people that i
preach to on a regular basis in church
um i the video i just put out this
morning i've been looking at oliver
sax's work and he had a really lovely
chapter on the simple
and um
the the simple are those who can't do
abstraction but they very clearly live
in the world of the concrete
and
i i was struck in listening to that
chapter in his book the man who um who
mistook his his wife for a hat
um there's a there's a level here
of
of practicality
and
so
so okay i look at this and i hear i mean
someone like nate up in the uk saying oh
this is just gibberish and i talked to
him on twitter a little bit this and i
probably will talk to him again about it
but i i think it's
i think still in sort of a modernist
world view
people look at this conversation and
think well
this will help me get what i want
instead of understanding that
this will change what you want
yeah
yeah that's a great way to say it
this will change what you think is good
what you think is beautiful and what you
think is true
and it's actually at that level of
transformation
that
uh we do need to be changed
and i i think i think part of what's
powerful in let's say
having these conversations with with
john verveiki with jordan and with let's
say david fuller is that in some ways
um
you know because these individuals are
are on the different side of the the
christian line let's say in some ways
that
i think for the church i mean where i
come at this thing is as a preacher
intelligibility
is key
and what's been happening for the last
200 years in a lot of ways
is that we've seen the church
accommodating to modernity
and trying to do that translation
through it and now i think we're
beginning to see it from the other side
where
there's at least been enough of a sea
change that the church can point to
things that are not modern
they might be older than modernity and
they include things that are now coming
after modernity but the church can begin
to make intelligible
for me it's it's making the bible
intelligible again actually because
that's that's my main job as a preacher
to make the bible intelligible
and the more i
you know the deeper i got into lewis
let's say
and you know part of the reason his book
miracles has been
i i
i it to be quite honest i remember
seeing jordan peterson and i'd seen
something there that was in the biblical
series and then in his classroom
lectures i said wow this is really
helpful
in
because i've been reading c.s lewis's
book miracles like two three times a
year for a couple of years wow to sort
of combat
modernity in me because i just i just
felt myself
increasingly becoming a reductionist
modernist
and i knew part of me knew in my
formation that this was this was
untenable this this this this doesn't
fundamentally work
and so then when i was listening to
jordan i was connecting it with some of
what lewis was saying in that in that
book miracles and i thought boy jordan
should really read this book and then i
thought i could send him the book but
that's pointless so then i thought what
i really have to do is i shouldn't
really worry so much about jordan but i
should i should address his audience
and so that's that's really how this
thing got started for me
now
part of the irony and and sometimes
frustration and all of this sort of
thinky talky space which i think is
essential and i obviously participate in
it and we have that at the conference
but part of the reason i'm so excited
about
the conference coming up in thunder bay
is
exactly what john said at the end of
your conversation with jordan and john
and is that and what jordan said too is
that
when we're having these conversations
in the same room
when we're physically together
i i get a sense that
you can make more progress that you're
actually
the physicality the embodiment you're
actually making more progress
in these areas that let's say
the words on a page or the speech
captured in a video
can't fundamentally capture
i think you're absolutely right and i
mean my experience of when i
went to toronto and spent those two days
with john viveki for example i felt like
our conversation really jumped
quite
really jumped a lot a lot farther i like
i finally understood
what he meant when why at least i
finally understood at least why he
resisted the the notion of narrative as
being let's say the basic substructure
and why he
why he
and so i finally got it like okay i
understand because there is
this
basic ontological hierarchy which is not
let's say a narrative and you see it
like the story of moses is the best
example right so it's like the law is
not a story right it's it's
i still like how can i say this like i
still think that it's it's it's anchored
in the story but i think that there's a
there's an importance to
this order of beings that we have to
attend to and so it's like i was like oh
i finally understand why or at least
what he's what he was trying to get to
when we were talking so to me that was a
massive breakthrough um and also i think
the more we've been discussing about
beauty and with has been a massive
breakthrough those conversations as well
so i'm really excited for sure to
to be with people but not just not just
you guys although i'm looking forward to
seeing you guys it's also just having
people around that are
that are interested that are curious and
you know having informal moments of
discussion and sitting around a table
at dinner and those things are very
precious you know we
luckily now we
you know with kovid you know with kobit
uh let's say i would say i won't say
ending but at least with covid not being
an issue anymore you know we have that
at the parish again like we have it in
our church we have coffee hour and we
have that camaraderie and that that
communion but that is so
precious i mean that has
so much value to to to be able to be
with people and to exchange and it's
funny that we'd say that as if it's not
a normal thing to do but it's become
very it's become almost exceptional
because we're so caught up in this this
online space you know
well and and yeah i love how earlier you
talked about body and of course in in
christian terminology that's that's
christian language when we gather
together on sunday or during the week or
in our homes or let's say in an estuary
group we are we are creating we are
creating
body uh we have the body politic
political parties are have you know our
bodies um i mean that's the language
that obviously paul started in yeah you
know in corinthians and that has
permeated the western world it's
completely you know under betting our
politics
and
i think you know my my questions
and and my desires when i
okay so i'm watching you and john and
jordan talk and david fuller you know
i'm going to be in the uk i'm going to
i'm going to get together with david i'm
going to get together with justin we're
going to have a bunch of estuary groups
part of part of also what i what i
really
i think part of the challenge we face
is is that of celebrity
in that um
we
we see jordan you jonathan me perhaps to
a degree
and
even though let's say in the early
church i think church fathers
bishops were in some ways celebrities
you look at cyprian you look at
augustine um
i don't think this
i think this dynamic of celebrity has
everything to do with attention
but i do think that
the goal
of for me the goal of all of this stinky
talky stuff has to be
knitting people together
into bodies
yeah that because i think we are we are
far more transformed by
our how we are in these bodies than we
are through
the
the fire hose of abstracted
talk
that is coming at us into these things
we're putting on our ears
or into our eyeballs yeah i i mean
that's why i always that's why i tell
people go to church in the sense that i
think that yeah this has to hit the road
like it and it it's also
it's also what makes what we're talking
about
real in the sense that i'd say my
like my brother and i's notion of
symbolism is obviously embodied it's not
something which is just floating up
there and i think also that the manner
in which john viveki talks about
relevant realization he doesn't see it
as just a mental process he sees it as
an embodied reality right uh move moving
in space and and encountering things so
so i think that we're not
let's say that we're not gnostics and
it's very important and that's also one
of the things that
will make this this project whatever it
is
will make it successful because it is
trying
not in the ways that the more that the
that the rationalists and the modernist
thought but it is trying to bridge
the word of the world of phenomena with
the say these spiritual ideals it's but
it's not doing it through
chemistry or like you know like the way
that the weird ways that that people
have tried to do it uh like creationism
or that kind of stuff but it it's trying
to do it in a
still really in an embodied way so it's
it's it's connecting your experience to
your daily life to
to these higher understandings and so
and that like it scales right it's not
just you and it it has to it has to
embody itself in your family and in
the intermediary communities and in
church and
you know one of the things that jordan
for example has said is the best thing
you can do right now is like you know
clean your room and become a better
person
but
there's also the scaling there's also
because one of the problems of the
modern world or the contemporary world
is that it
you know there's an extreme of chaos and
an extreme order is the best way to
understand it you have you how you see
the states and these these organizations
even corporations becoming more and more
powerful more of more authority they
could say coercive and and
and authoritative and also permeating
your space and then we see the people
becoming
reduced to their idiosyncrasies as much
as possible like to your little thing
and so a normal world when we talk about
these embedded hierarchies the normal
world
is mediated all the way through
and and it's interesting paul because
i've been thinking about this in terms
of exodus for example it seems like
that's something one of the things
that's going on in exodus where god is
like god is this raging fire like god
will destroy everything you know and
then the people are in egypt and you
know it's they're all scattered you know
they're a bunch of slaves they're mixed
multitude and god's like okay i want to
make you to a people but if i if i co if
if if i connect with you it's just going
to burn you so we have to create this
mediating structure between and it's
it's both the law but it's also the the
structure of uh of authority of the the
you know the thousand the hundred the
tense the whatever the fifty the tens
that gets set up so you get this
mediating reality of small embedded
structures in each other it's like
that's how it works that's how it works
but the modern world wants to
reduce
have all this power up here and reduce
us to individuals so one of the best
things you can do and it's just like is
really go to church or join a team or
be part of an actual
group of people that are working
together you know that that are that are
together
towards a common attention
and it's a normal thing for humans to do
but it's something which has been made
harder
by covid by by the internet by you know
getting caught up in these these online
spaces so
so it really is embodying this stuff
at different levels in a family in in
the church and in a group is the
is necessary or else it's not going to
have fruits it's not gonna
yeah well i think one of the key
elements of this is the very anti-modern
i i think you said it very well the
individualism the the anti-modern
practice of commitment
i think
i mean john talks about transcendence i
don't think there's any more powerful
self transcendence than the
the sacrificial burden
of a
costly commitment
um you you that happens when you
let's say you marry
because you you say okay
i'm sure that
if i live another 50 60 years after this
marriage i will find another um
attractive person that i think is better
for me than you
um i am sure that i am going to find
jobs and opportunities that will take me
away from you and and so in a commitment
you say
you know in in the old english vowels
forsaking all others it's like well
you're going to do that in your 20s you
know think about all of the optimization
you're going to turn your back away from
for the sake of this
and and so then it then with children it
becomes even more because children are
these little you know they start out
these little parasitic blood suckers
that they take all your money they take
all your time they take all your
attention they you know they're just
such greedy little things but if you
actually devote yourselves to them
and you pour yourself into them
then they actually grow up and they
thems themselves can become you know
people who uh people who love and give
and sacrifice for others so it's this
it's this dance that creates but
um i think part of
part of what this what
what this depends upon
is the the making and keeping of
commitments and especially i think
i think the orthodox church has seemed i
don't know i don't really know the
church much but the orthodox church has
seemed to maintain
some of that better than at least in a
lot of protestant churches now
commitment is sort of the complete
opposite of consumerism
where consumerism is i'm going to act on
what i perceive my best interest is now
and the moment that i perceive those
interests and desires changing i'm going
to hop to the new thing yeah i'm gonna
hop to the new partner i'm gonna hop to
the new job i'm gonna and there's a
degree to which you know when it comes
to
uh where you buy your things or
that level is appropriate for a bunch of
things in life but if that then becomes
connected if that's the way you approach
everything in life and i think you know
even you know i've talked about about my
channel before
the the churn i mean youtube understands
that
okay you're watching vander clay now
you're watching pejo now you're watching
peterson now you're watching viveki now
youtube doesn't care who you watch yeah
just that you watch yeah yeah
so i you know i think even though on one
hand
we're certainly making use of
this medium
i think we do our audience a disservice
if we don't continue to
remind them that it's going to be in
having in real life commitments to one
another
and a face-to-face way
all of this talk about
self-improvement self-transcendence
none of that is going to happen if you
don't if the
if the tyranny of the individual
isn't broken and the
the most obvious breaking of that is by
keeping making and keeping commitments
that makes sense that's that i think
that's true and also the idea that
commitments
you have scale of commitments that's
super important too because one of the
issues so when you were talking i was
thinking you know there there are
right now let's say cults that will
understand that
and they use that they weaponize it
right so they they actually demand so
much commitment from you they demand
supreme commitment
and then in doing that and so you think
why would anybody join a cult right and
it's actually because people
know that it's fulfilling to to be
committed to something and to kind of
give yourself to it uh and so cults will
weaponize that and so you can recognize
the difference between a cult and a real
commitment
uh whereas
a cult or a parasitic type of
relationship like that will demand all
from you
right we'll demand all and will see any
other commitment you have as competing
with whatever commitment you give them
uh and so that's a good way for just
people watching or listening to know the
difference and you so you know it's like
even in your relationship like if you
you're in a relationship with someone
with let's say a man with a woman and
then that person wants you to give up
all your friends and give up your family
and give up give up you know and and
renounce your your parents and
everything it's like okay well
no like that's not that's not a good
relationship that's a bad relationship
that's a you know the only thing that
you know that's why we have the idea of
god like god is the only one who can
demand all our commitment
and then thankfully he gives it back to
us in in in fractal
participation right in marriage in
churches and in friendships and all of
that so so that's one way to see the
difference but you're right that if we
find these these healthy places to
to commit ourselves then then that's
that's how yeah that's how
that's one of the embodied ways that we
can deal with the meaning crisis
what what do you hope what do you hope
for people who now i talked to catherine
and i they've sold about 100 tickets
they had 60 airsoft tickets and
apparently jonathan john and i are all
going to participate in the airsoft
which and i fully expect that we are
going to get pegged that's right more
than anybody else just by virtue of
hierarchy of attention and you also by
virtue of a hierarchy of scale like
you're just gonna be so much taller than
all of us that everybody's gonna be
shooting at paul
we're gonna get massacred yeah but
in terms of um
in terms of the people well i
i very much want people to come to this
conference and i think
i think there will be for for those who
are watching online
who can come to this concert now i
realize that thunder bay is a difficult
place to get to yeah if you're in a
commitment though paul it's a commitment
that's right it's a commitment if you're
i am not actually my first one i looked
at air flights i first looked at okay i
gotta fly got like two steps into
toronto then i'm gonna spend the night
then i gotta get to thunder bay and i
decided no i'm going to have one flight
over to minneapolis and then we're going
to do a road trip from minneapolis up to
uh up to thunder bay because it's only
about five hour drive from from
from minneapolis and minneapolis for
those you know say flying from other
places in the world uh who can get into
america which is not always easy um but
those who are in the united states who
want to get to thunder bay i would very
much recommend get to minneapolis and
then
get up from minneapolis to thunder bay
what do you want for people who listen
to your channel and have been
let's say how can i say this
because i don't because again
i don't think what we really want is
fans
i know i
one of the great things about this
conference that i'm looking forward to
is that we're there for several days and
so
and it's also going to be limited you
know they have a limit of people that
can come so it's like i think they said
300 would be the limit but they're
thinking more like 150 maybe
uh you know 200 people and so it's like
200 people if you spend three days
together two days together
it's not the same like you have time to
well you know we'll eat we'll sit we'll
talk there'll be a lot of breathing room
and so i think that that will be
in some ways
very refreshing compared to you know the
one-stop evening uh you know
presentation and then a few questions at
the end uh that's really what i'm
looking forward to really is to have
just time and to and yes as to end with
you and with john and to to be let's say
to have to be able to talk with you and
john and have other people sitting
around that are that are chiming in that
are that are giving their their ideas um
yeah that's what that's definitely what
i'm looking most forward to and i think
that it will
it will i think it will cement and i
think people will create relationships
there as well like
because a lot of them say the zimbabwe
people are the estuary people they meet
online but yeah going there meeting in
the flesh spending a few days together
that will definitely cement and i
definitely see people visiting each
other and then calling each other
afterwards and staying in touch that
would that's definitely what i hope yeah
that's that's what i hope for too and
the
the thing that i've
appreciated most over these last four
years has been i'm trying to get rick to
go now rick's going to listen to this
he's going to it's really
he's got to get a passport first but um
but even even the idea of going to
minneapolis you know carpooling doing a
road trip together as a minister i've
often found that um
car time with people yeah in our culture
is really valuable because
you know the cell phone doesn't work
that well um you're in a car
you're just you're in that confined
space for a number of hours with people
you you can gain a level of fellowship
of personal knowledge you can find
people that you actually click with and
can maybe you know build longer
friendships you know friendships again i
just saw a video someone was saying that
generation z is the loneliest generation
which is
you know astounding given the fact that
we're all running around with these
little devices in our pocket that it
supposedly connects us to the world the
quality of that connection
is
is weak no for sure yeah kids don't
right now kids don't see each other a
lot they they they are they're on
instagram or on snapchat or whatever
sending each other photos and and
writing text but they there's hard
you know it's not
i notice it like even my kids they
actually my kids see a lot of
their friends maybe more than a lot of
people but they still i feel like you
know when we were kids during the summer
you would you would spend all day with
their people like you just go you would
leave in the morning and then you just
spent all day with people and then you
come back home and that's not the case
like it's not it might be happening
somewhere but it's definitely not
happening around here uh so it's just so
so you're right these friendships are
going to become more and more
going to become more and more precious
as time kind of kind of moves forward
and we'll have to be deliberate about it
we can't just think it's going to happen
well and i also think a lot of the
the self-improved so
there's a
there's a lot of this sort of
self-improvement stuff on the internet
right now and in some ways we're sort of
adjacent to that given clean up your
room and you know jordan's sort of in a
self-help thing yeah his couple of his
books but i think and a lot of that
focuses on well eating better and
cleaning your room and having a better
job
i suspect that part of what's going on
with gen z is that they haven't
developed the interpersonal skills
to really build
lifelong
relationships with one another because
the only way you can actually build
those skills
is to be with people just spend a lot a
lot of huge amounts of time with people
exactly
and learn that talking in a certain way
or talking about certain things that
doesn't really
progress the conversation and then
learning how
to read the subtle cues from someone
else to engage in a conversation and you
know as jordan says you engage in the
conversation in order to have a next
conversation and another conversation
and to allow the relationship to go
deeper and to be more stable and and so
i i think that
i i think that part of you know all of
these skills are
there they're basically
necessary for having a
a satisfying church life
a satisfying romantic relationship
a satisfying relationship with a parent
or a child or a cousin or a sibling
and
you know it sounds
i i hope that if people are there's a
lot of digital i won't call them digital
nomads i won't call them digital monks
i'll call them digital recluses
for the digital recluses to
get out from behind the screens
and be in a car with people
and
have to do all of that
difficult work of
learning to relate build a relationship
build a friendship maintain a friendship
um feed a friendship because i think all
of this is actually the knitting
that builds
these bodies that we're talking about
definitely and so what about you in
terms of the estuary because you're
doing this little estuary tour tell me a
bit about that you're going you're going
to europe uh and and so so who are these
people like how many are there
it's it's hard to know
um
so i am doing a bunch of
um more conferency type things so in
this all got started because the german
estuary decided they wanted to do a
festival
and so they've got a band called two
more v's well two more v is gonna be
there yeah yeah i know i know so two
more visas gonna do music and they got
burn power coming over from tbilisi
georgia wow and i'm and then um
[Music]
um matea said to me he said you know
well if we paid your way would you come
and i thought yeah i'd come and then
john vindonk was like well if you're
going there anyway why don't we make it
a big thing so
the the german festival started it out
and then the hollanders got together and
said you know well let's use that to
kick off our dutch estuary the
netherlands is small enough that you
know people can get around pretty easily
so i'm talking to a guy who was their
national theologian and a journalist and
another philosopher so we're doing a
conversation there i think we're having
another um estuary type group there so
we're going to launch a couple of dutch
estuaries the german estuary has been
going well so they're going to have a
festival and they want to make that a
yearly thing one of the things i was
just in chicago one of the things that
i've been noting is that
these estuaries like the chicago estuary
they meet together
quite regularly but every year now
they're doing a bigger event
okay draw a little bit more attention
and organize themselves and give them
sort of a project that they can push
themselves to and i think that's pretty
helpful
so i'm meeting with some theologians in
the netherlands and then the german
festival and then john van donk and i
are taking a train through switzerland
through france under the tunnel all the
way to the uk yeah um and then i'm going
to go up to
ireland northern ireland and i'm going
to do an event with um marcus yeah
that's so amazing i'm so jealous of that
like i would oh man you're making me so
jealous yeah it's going to be a little
bad so tickets i've got the i'll put the
links below for these things you can
still get tickets for that
and then i come back down to london and
i'm doing an event with um
with glenn scrivner and tom holland nice
whoa this amazing paul that's gonna be
wonderful so i think there might still
be uh things available for that
and then i'm preaching in a little
church in london that's actually one of
the things i'm most excited about
preaching at church in london oh yeah
there's a little church
and i and the church writes me but we're
a little church i've got a little church
i much prefer a little church because we
can see each other yeah and so i'm
preaching in a little church in london
and then we've um i'm going to meet with
justin brierly a little bit and i'm
going to meet with david fuller and i'm
going to have another estuary meeting in
salisbury i think there's a few other
estuary meetings that are going we're
going to have a meeting in manchester
just an estuary group and i hope uh i
hope nate um comes down for that because
uh nate's been uh nate's been critical
and i i you know the book of proverbs
talks about the fact that in many ways
you know our critics can be a blessing
because they can open us up to maybe
things we're not seeing so i think um i
think i'll i'll have a good time nate
and i have talked he's he's he's one of
the few guys that managed to get himself
banned twice from the bridges of mean
discord surfer
he had joe ban him but um
but you know as a pastor i deal with
that you know you're always dealing with
sheep that behave badly so i have a i
have a heart for sheep that behave badly
that's amazing that sounds like so it's
all going to be recorded most of it it's
going to be
i'll i think the bigger events are going
to be recorded
i don't know
we'll have to see
and then we're also hopefully so there's
another guy who's been talking about
he's a hollywood um
cameraman and he was just down in greece
filming a sequel to the big fat greek
wedding okay and he's gonna come up and
he's actually been talking about
um
thinking about doing a documentaries
that he teaches documentary filmmaking
at biola
and he's starting to think about
what would what would a documentary look
like focusing on this little corner of
the internet well that'd be interesting
because there's a lot of attention going
to jordan
but um i
i'm i'm more excited by
what i hope we're knitting together with
me and you and john and estuary
and i you know part of what estuary for
me is about from a church perspective
is
that
churches you know church has to continue
to do what church does
but there's been a there's been a gulf
between the church and the culture
and there are a lot of fundamental
misunderstandings
about what church is and what church is
for yeah and and there's a lot of
you know
given given the history of church in the
west and perhaps to the east in the
eastern church as well there's a lot of
anxiety
among non-churched people about churches
at a cult is it uh is it something
that's tyrannical yeah and um i think i
think anybody who's you know there
certainly are tyrannical churches and
tyrannical pastors for sure
but anybody who's had a living healthy
relationship in a church should
understand that
church is fundamentally not tyrannical
we talked about making and keeping
commitments that's a making and keeping
commitments is a different thing from a
tyranny that's right it's hard because
some people today let's say might think
that that's that that's it like
a lot of people seem to think that just
authority itself any authority is is
immediately tyrannical
but that's not
usually that's not especially in a
church because the thing about a church
is that it's not you're not um
especially now like there's no one
compelling you to go to church and so
it's a negotiation like even if there is
real authority it's always going to be a
negotiation because it's not like uh
not like there are any consequences to
you not going to church especially now
so yeah
and and and yet well i i thought your
conversation i think it's with glenn
when you talked about authority
i i'd love to hear you talk more about
authority
in some of these venues because
so my wife is an elementary school
teacher and
she is she's she's in a waldorf program
so she went um first grades first
through eight with her class i remember
that first class that she sort of
graduated i mean those kids
gosh those kids would those kids would
do anything for her because what she did
through those eight years was she's very
demanding she runs a very tight ship in
terms of that classroom
but she can do that because she pays
very close attention to each of them as
an individual and the kids very quickly
pick up that she wants what's best for
them yeah and so it's not tyranny it's
love
yeah
yeah but it you can see it like there's
also i mean i think everybody's had that
experience in school i remember my best
teachers
were actually not like the the the just
the nice teachers the ones that are just
trying to buddy up to you and to you
know they're actually the teachers that
were both
demanding
and strict
but involved and caring so it's like you
know they they will put in the work
they'll put in the time they will pay
attention they'll listen to you they'll
listen to your question they'll take
them seriously but you better step up
and
you know so there's a sense in which
it's a
though that seems to be
at least in terms of authority
understanding that for sure if authority
doesn't love then
that's not how it works right i mean
saint paul sets it up pretty clearly
it's like
the authority has to love and then the
the the
the people that are submitted to that
authority have to submit but it's a it
goes both ways right it's like if you
don't you can complain let's say you can
be an authority and you can complain
that nobody's
listening to you if you you know but and
you can say well they should you know
this is god's way like they should
listen with like okay you can say that
as much as you want but it's still not
going to work it's not going to happen
so so i think yeah
the question of it and just i mean i
think it has to do with hierarchy people
don't understand also that hierarchy is
always negotiation not in a bad way not
in the sense of like a
like a fight or some kind of conflict
but it's a negotiation in the sense that
whatever thing wants to find body
has to deal with the body it's going to
find right it's like a maple tree
growing in a
in let's say on a rock won't has to
negotiate its body out of what is
possible for it so the the structure of
a tree
will be related to the soil in which it
is and that is just a natural
relationship between the pattern and its
instantiation and that is true for any
type of of hierarchy any type of
authority there is a negotiation between
the pattern and
the structure and the and the potential
that will instantiate it
there's there's no way around it's not
never just top down top down is not is
not at least not i don't think there's
any way to argue that top down is the
christian way of seeing the world like
it's a it's a it's a call-in response
like the song of songs that's why that's
why you know the fathers see the song of
songs as
this relationship between god and man
but you can see it fractally as this
relationship between authority and those
that are submitted to it as this as this
call and response of two lovers that
respond to each other
and want to come together so
well i think that's why
we want to
create
bodies
that i think that's why we meet together
because
you know
the attention the love part of the part
of the
i remember once you saying that you know
these screens and people looking at us
right now we are beings of light
but we are
in that way the screens are deceptive
yeah because
um myself you john verbaki jordan
peterson any of us if you meet us in
person
part of you is going to definitely be
disappointed that's right that's for
sure
we will and and one of the huge
disappointments that i think the
deceitfulness of
their these technologies are a blessing
but there's a deception in them
yeah in that right now this is a very
immediate relationship
that
oh i i feel like paul gets me i don't
get you at all i don't see you at all
i'm looking at a camera and a screen
here and i've even you know i haven't
even gotten to know john and jonathan
beyond you know conversations less than
one on one hand that's not real
knowledge no yeah um and i've certainly
listened to them plenty and thought
about them in germs but but the
you you cannot really form a body uh a
durable life-giving
authoritative yet loving body
without
you know immediate relationship and just
by virtue of the dunbar number i think
part of what made jordan so powerful
especially in those early years was that
he was able to connect both
he had authority and people would again
and again say that to me oh he's you
know he speaks as one with authority oh
okay i've heard that before um
but partly because it on one hand he he
was able to make a
um a credible demand of people that
people could say yeah i should clean my
room yeah i i'm sponging off my parents
i'm i'm wasting my life
that's a credible appeal and a credible
challenge but at the same time you'd see
him when he was talking about the
loss of humanity that let's say someone
living in their mother's basement
covered and covered in cheetos dust
doing video games and porn all the time
you know when he would break down into
tears about such a person you saw then
that mixing of
challenge
and
care and love but
and the screen sort of said well he
cares about you well
to the degree that you're participating
in in the fraternity of porn and cheetos
dust perhaps but that's not much of a
fraternity to be a that's not much
that's not a good body to be a part of
no um
yeah well it's a spark like it's a it's
a spark that can lead you to
into something real which is why i think
like it's i mean i think that
both of us have have had different ways
of going about it like i think the
estuary that definitely seems to be what
you're trying to do is saying okay well
we need to get this to land you know uh
and and i'm focusing more on the church
idea but the estuary is like an
intermediary space like a space of you
know a bubbling space of discussion and
exploration that i think is also super
necessary right now and part of for me
estuary always has two problems one of
it is i'd love people to form groups
make a body participate in it commit to
it
figure out how to make that a
life-giving life life-producing
network of relationships but the other
part for me is admonishing the churches
to say
look why aren't you doing that
yes
why is it that no one imagines a church
would be a good place to go to
in order to get into a body that
you know that has these kinds of
conversations i see what you've done in
terms of your symbolic world
in a rather estuary way so you have here
you have the church fathers here you
have the church but
you are translating that and trying to
make it intelligible via symbolism
to a much broader audience
and and and some have figured that out
and then found their way into the church
um
i you know as a preacher that's always
in a sense been mine but i've seen
the church as so at least the protestant
church in some ways
has
was so formative of modernity
and especially in the 19th 18th and 19th
century
they they thought they could basically
retranslate the bible
into
into science and yield
of technology
that would i mean there's there's a real
difficulty in protestantism there yeah
and
yet for you know that people say well
why are you still protestant well
because i'm committed to a body
i'm committed to i'm committed to lots
of bodies these are my people and so
um at one point someday you and i are
gonna have to have a longer conversation
about the protestant reformation which
which would be absolutely fun but um
yeah i also do it in private with like a
glass of beer and you know or bourbon
and cigar or something which was exactly
what lewis said lewis said protestant
reformation should have been a
conversation of that nature rather than
what it ended up being so
so yeah so there's there's so there's
thunder bay coming up and there's my
europe trip are you are you doing any
anything look there's a lot of stuff i
mean there's a lot of stuff coming up
it's all none of it is super clear like
i it's i mean people have noticed that
i've been that jordan peterson has kind
of
kind of taken me along i guess is the
way to say it he's like all right
jonathan let's go there let's do this
and i'm like okay sure why not like i'm
you know i love it uh we did this this
uh we did this 10 year 10 day seminar on
exodus
uh which was great which a lot of fun we
didn't finish the book we actually got
to the law basically in 10 days which is
crazy but you know it was a lot of it
was like a wild conversation uh dennis
frager was there and then greg hurwitz
stephen blackwood for people who kind of
followed jordan have seen him uh and uh
james orr
from the uk so it was it was great it
was wonderful um and so i'm probably i'm
probably going to the uk in september
okay so there might be some events there
but it's nothing is clear yet so okay so
at least for now it's like it's thunder
bay people come to thunder bay so this
this seminar on on exodus any of this
recorded or was this pretty much it's
all recorded oh no it was recorded like
daily wire recorded it was it was like
you know with five cam six cameras and
lighting and the set and and makeup and
it was like it was so like another world
i like being in another world but i mean
it was it was great it was wonderful
like i really i did enjoy my time there
and a lot of down time also with all
these people you know just chatting and
discussing and so that was great but uh
but yeah it's definitely hype high
production
well i would love to see um
because you know as a pastor i know you
say okay people should oh i'm gonna
start reading the bible they go through
genesis like oh genesis was great and i
go through exodus and you get the sinai
and wow exodus is great and then after
cyanide yeah we're not there yet i know
i keep telling like okay you you we
better like we'd better set up
some
some some notions or you better set up
some structures of understanding how
this is applicable right now because
when we get to take a sword and cross
the camp and slash as much as you can
like when we get to kill all the you
know it's like you we better have a way
to understand this because
like our ideals about freedom and
whatever
like all this stuff that people want to
put into exodus and about like freedom
from slavery and all this stuff like you
better be ready because what's coming is
rough and i think there's there's way
there are ways to talk about it i think
the church fathers have ways to to
discuss it if we understand reality
fractally then then the application that
is made personally
is not just a metaphor it's not just
it's actually not just a like an
arbitrary allegory that the fathers came
up with it's actually applying the
pattern of the story to
yourself you know and then the
sacrifices become self-sacrifices right
the egyptian that you kill is the one in
inside you and so it's a transformation
of the interpretation into to the person
and and then all of it can be applicable
uh but unless we do that then
good luck like good luck with the with
the with the purging of the camp there
fellows
well not only that but also the
the furnishings of the tabernacle yeah
like how are you gonna understand any of
that stuff right why all of these
chapters god is giving detailed
instructions on this is what the
tabernacle is supposed to look like i
mean it's it's almost like he's i always
liking it sort of like that the
tabernacle is sort of like a nuclear
containment unit because what happens
often is god breaks out into the camp
and people die
and and so the kind of attention given
to
the furnishings of the tabernacle the
um the rituals it ends with the
description of the tabernacle yes and so
but that's the body like that's the
embodiment that we're talking about it's
like the final embodiment
of all of this where it's leading to
which is an embodiment of sacrifice and
worship like that's actually the
mediating so all the mediating
principles are now in place in terms of
the law and in terms of space and in
terms of relationships of people and and
relationships of authority all of this
has now been established and now it's
practiced it's right and people always
think that the that what happens on
sinai is just about a bunch of moral
code you're supposed to use like you
said it's actually mostly about the
tabernacle it's mostly about an order of
worship an order of procession right a
manner in which we engage with each
other
in in in a in a
ritual worship sacrifice sense that's
actually what's probably
the prime the prime drive of where we're
going in terms of of of exodus so so but
that's all related to what we're talking
about it's very exodus is actually i'm
really happy that we're doing exodus
because exodus is really about the
discussion that we're having now and
understanding the relationship between
the embodied
practice which which
instantiates these patterns that are
that are above and that's what exodus is
about the whole time and some of it does
include
you know having to remove the patterns
or remove the things that don't fit
and it looks weird in the text because
it does look weird in the text it's like
well yeah it's killing a bunch of people
i understand that that's that's
difficult but it's like you can either
just be annoyed and angry and just just
scream and shout fine or you could try
to understand it and realize that you
know
whatever you get involved with that has
this pattern
you're gonna do that right it's like if
you're
if you're in a basketball team and then
someone comes with a baseball bat you're
going to say i'm sorry you need to go
home because this is not what we're
doing we have to purge you from this
team because this is not
it does not fit with the aim that we're
that we're going to uh and so so unless
we are able to
to look beyond i mean i don't want to
minimize
the madness or some of the things that
look really crazy to people in that book
but if we want if we don't if we
if we want to understand it then we need
to to be able to to see
how it what it what it's referring to in
terms of a pattern and in terms of
embodiment so anyways sorry but it's
like we're not there yet because we're
just at the law like we've just
basically in in the the exit seminar
we've come to the ten commandments and
we've read the ten commandments
and then that's it like we didn't even
interpret them because
so but there's already some of it like
when you see moses going up
you see the problem like when moses goes
up the hill and then the people forget
him and then they make the golden calf
and it's like it's like okay so mo you
know so because god says
to moses your will be god to aaron right
you will be god to aaron and then aaron
will be your mouth to the people and so
you can imagine it's like the hierarchy
it's a hierarchy of manifestation so
then moses leaves
and then aaron makes a golden calf it's
like that's how it works folks it's like
if you don't stay connected then these
things at the bottom become idols and so
unless they're connected all through
then that's what that's the problem
that's when things become idols and so
it's it already makes i think people are
going to be able to
people who watch our content like people
who who listen to john or watch my
videos and everything will be able to
understand you know
what what's going on in the books of
exodus because it's all about that
well i
you know there's the there's definitely
the problem of um
let's say canaanite slaughter so we've
we've got those issues but to me also
the question is you've got the second
half of the book of exodus which is all
about furnishing in the tabernacle how
does the tabernacle function and then
you've sort of got the decalogue the ten
words but then you've got all of these
particular other little laws yeah and
then of course that's going to lead to
leviticus which is even more of that and
then it's going to lead to deuteronomy
which is sort of a i remember in
seminary doing a little bit of a
detailed study between the laws and
exodus and comparable laws in
deuteronomy and the changes between them
of course that gets in biblical
scholarship that gets into a whole thing
but the i mean a lot of the heart of the
conversation
is okay how do we then live
um because quite clearly the tabernacle
and the more specific laws flow out of
the exodus and the decalogue
and it's all the application
and i think
you know part of what i would like to
hear from you and from jordan and
especially in conversation with others
we have some um we have some
some jewish um members in our bridges of
meaning community
um is okay how do we deal with
you know okay you can't weave you know
you can't wear a garment of two fabrics
i mean all of that that's super easy to
understand by the way paul yeah that was
super easy but that's the low-hanging
fruit yeah yeah um the temperature
yeah why the tabernacle is set up the
way it is like
i i think that some of the details of
the tabernacle i think are definitely
obscure to me like there's some like you
know the hoops and the like some of it
becomes like okay like at least in terms
of meaning like it seems like okay well
you need hoops to hold the thing and
that and i hate because we were like oh
jonathan's saying just right
transcendence just to hold the thing
uh
but i i just because i don't i don't
totally enlighten but in terms of the
basic structure of the tabernacle i
think that it's extremely coherent in
terms of uh in terms of an ontological
hierarchy and it actually repeats the
story in genesis it's actually it's it's
almost a narrative repetition of the
fall moving from the tree you know the
candelabra let's say and the the the
cherub on the altar so you have a little
mini paradise and then you have bigger
versions of it moving all the way to the
to the garments of skin uh and then
ultimately to the to the altar of the
fire on the outside the fire and water
on the outside you have the the lava and
you have the
so it's like you see it like it's an
exodus right the fire the column of fire
and the column of water in exodus are
related to what you end up finding in
the the the tabernacle a good way for
people to understand it is that during
the plagues those get mixed up it's like
there's fire and water and it's
destroying and it's all mixed and then
god separates that into two guiding
principles two pillars you could say and
then those end up in ultimately in the
tabernacle they also end up ultimately
in the temple as yakin and boaz as the
two pillars of the of the temple and so
there's a structural element like to
understand the structure the thing is
i'm not sure one of the things i think i
might do is
because obviously this is a conversation
between eight people and so
you know i was you always measure like
you're like okay when should i make it
when should i make
say something and i need to make it
impactful i need to make it relevant one
of the things i might do is when the
exodus seminar comes out i might make my
own
exodus like good
you know just to kind of say well if you
like what i'm saying there and you like
what jordan's saying there you want more
like here's here's uh here's a bunch of
videos that go through exodus as well so
i'm thinking about doing that just
because
obviously some people are going to tell
me like why didn't you say this like why
didn't you i was like you know it's like
you you're with eight people so you
you you find the moment and you you try
to measure your your your
involvement so but it was fun it was a
lot it was a lot of fun
where did you do it
in miami we recorded in miami oh did
someone have a place in miami or was it
just kind of a rented space that they
use well daily wire daily wire they
basically run out of two places out of
nashville and in miami oh okay and so
they rented us they have a staff studio
they went there and they have a team
that comes to film and so
okay yeah well
any idea when that's going to be
released i think it's in november
but i think it's for the daily wire plus
i think that's what i that's my
understanding there we go i got my i
paid for my year because it was cheaper
a month
someone on twitter right away when that
got announced someone had twitter this
means paul vander clay's going to get a
daily wire plus subscription i thought
no i'm not going to do it it was a day
later i bought it it's like why not i
got to do
it well i mean yeah because i mean some
of the contents of these definitely i
think i think they're going to do some
some public some they're going to do
both i don't know we'll see but i was
happy that the conversation with you and
john and jordan
that that was completely on youtube um i
was happy about that
and i understand i i totally understand
that for jordan
you know i say this and sometimes
sometimes people criticize me for saying
it
jordan had a life you know
he had a life he was a clinical
psychologist he was a university
professor you know he did his little
ontario public tv things and then he
spoke out and his life was taken away
from him yeah and so i don't begrudge
him he he's got years left in him
hopefully to to have a vocation and
and so now he you know he like brett
weinstein and you know they're kind of
you know
verveiki talks about domicide in terms
of their vocation jordan peterson and
and brett weinstein they were they were
sort of kicked out of their professions
and so
now they're living in this intel you
know public intellectual space and so i
understand that youtube is not probably
a stable reliable platform platform
necessarily for him so i don't think
that's something definitely to at least
in the long term as things get like as
things get closer to so now there's the
midterms but when we get to the next
election things are gonna get wild like
things are gonna get so crazy like we
have people don't like don't think that
you've seen it all like it's gonna get
really bad so in a way the people that
aren't in some ways at least aware and
preparing for that on on social media
and then make it in this space where
we're made using these these massive
google and these massive companies to
make content you know don't be naive
it's going to get next election cycle's
gonna get really bad so
which again is why i think people need
to
be embedded in a body yeah and they need
to have
um you know when you look at rod drears
latest book and when he talks about i
mean what what you have when these
mediating structures are sort of
liquefied by the chaos that's going on
what you really have are relationships
of trust where you look across the way
and say
i trust this person and i trust this
person not because they're saying all
the things i want to hear
but because i've been with them and i've
watched them
i've watched them live yeah and you know
no none of us are completely trustworthy
but we get a sense of what we can trust
people for and what we can't
and it's all that detailed
real life connection that finally um
that that you really need when
um when chaos reigns so yeah
yeah yeah what's that so that's paul's
last words you just go to church you
know find an estuary or at least some
club like a knitting club or something
like you know be connected with people
build your family ships with people
that's right learn to learn to build
relationships with people because again
my sense is with a lot of younger people
like you're right when we were growing
up
you were just with people there wasn't
any of these screens to be
with people through or to have this
deceptive form of community and those
are skills
you need to learn to develop and it's a
lot better than having a six-pack or
being your ideal weight or getting some
great degree or some you know some uber
great job the the the skill of
interpersonal relationship is the most
one of the most important skills you can
develop in your lifetime and
there's no other way to do it but by
doing it with people in real life
so there's my message that's great
pastor paul has spoken thanks thanks
this is great i definitely i'm looking
forward to seeing you very soon looking
forward to seeing you and and john too
and and and you know i've you know i've
gotten to know catherine and eamon who
are setting up this conference they're
great you know yeah they're quite well
and so i really look forward to
meeting with them in the flesh and yeah
so all right have a great trip to europe
too good place to land the plane yeah
and uh i hope i if i can find intricate
reliable internet connections from
europe i hope to have
you know unlike my vacations people
people on my channel have been you know
you're not putting out the content i'm
used to well if i can find internet
connections hopefully vendank and i will
talk and we'll have job in there and
we'll have matthias from germany and two
more vs and so hopefully stuff will keep
coming out that'll be different for my
vacation so
all right everybody all right jonathan
thanks a lot bye-bye bye-bye
hello everyone i want to invite you to
an event which will be happening from
september 16th to the 18th in thunder
bay ontario called consciousness and
conscience it is going to be a
conference where i will be there with uh
john verveiki with paul vander clay and
also with dr richard mondro for those
who follow the uh this little corner of
the internet you will see that this is
the closest thing to a conference
bringing us all together that we're
going to have in a little while it is
the closest thing to a symbolic world
conference as well
it's going to be several days of talks
of discussions and it's even going to
start a few days early on the 14th where
we're going to have an airsoft and
barbecue and it really shows you what is
the the purpose of this conference is to
to get together to discuss ideas to also
get to know each other so i'm really
excited to participate in this my own
talk will be called love and attention
and i'll be looking at the manner in
which love binds together our attention
and why i think that this is really the
glue of consciousness in general and
kind of one of the secrets to how
reality presents itself to you
and so but mostly really i'm looking
forward to being there with you guys
with paul vander clay who i've never met
with john vivek who i always love to be
together and discovering also dr richard
monroe who i don't know yet i think it's
going to be a wonderful event and i'm
really hoping to see you there if you
want to sign up go to urbanabby.ca
conference and look up consciousness and
conscience um i'm going to drive there
you know because of our situation in
canada i'm actually going to drive like
15 hours in order to get to the
conference so once i'm there i'm going
to be excited to uh to make the most of
the time i have with all you guys there
so i hope to see you there and to meet
you there and uh thanks